our thoughts
are with those killed
injured
and displaced
we call on russia to stop this senseless
war
immediately seize
its assaults
withdraw all its forces from ukraine
and turn back to the
path of
dialogue and
turn away from aggression
the kremlin's the kermit's objectives
are not limited to ukraine
russia has demanded legally binding
agreements
to announce
further nato enlargement
and remove troops and infrastructure
from allies that joined after 1997
we are
facing a new normal in european security
where russia openly contests the
european security order
and uses force
to pursue its objectives
the world will hold russia
and belarus accountable for their
actions
russia
as the aggressor
belarus as the enabler
president putin's decision to pursue his
aggression against ukraine
is a terrible strategic mistake
for which russia would pay a severe
price for years to come
nato allies and the european union have
already introduced significant sanctions
and many of our partners around the
globe have joined us
we must stand ready to do more
even if it means
we have to pay a price
because we are in this for the long haul
at the same time
the russian people must know
that kremlin's war on ukraine will not
make russia more secure
it will not make russia more respected
in the world
it will not lead to a better future for
your children
in response to russia's massive military
buildup over the past months we have
already strengthened our deterrence and
defense
yesterday
nato allies
activated our defense plans
and as a result we are deploying
elements of the nato response force
online
at sea and in the air
to further strengthen our posture
and to respond quickly to any
contingency
the united states
canada and european allies
have deployed thousands of more troops
to the eastern part of the alliance
we have over 100 jets
at high alert
operating in over 30 different locations
and over
120 ships
from the high north
to the mediterranean
including
fee strike carrier groups
there must be no space for
miscalculation or misunderstanding
we will do what it takes to protect and
defend every ally
and every inch of nato territory
leaders
today also made clear that we must
continue our support to ukraine
the kremlin is trying to make nato and
the eu provide less support to our
partners
so our collective answer must be more
support to countries like georgia
moldova
and bosnia devona
to help them succeed with their
democratic reforms
and pursue
the path that they have freely
chosen
more than ever this crisis demonstrates
the importance of north america and
europe standing together in nato
there is no security in europe without a
strong transatlantic bomb
with that i'm ready to take your
questions
okay we'll go to al jazeera
bay's al jazeera
how fearful are you about the possible
fall of kiev how long in your estimate
in your estimation
can the government of ukraine last and
if we move to a resistance
insurgency type situation what support
can nato then give
so what we see now is a full-fledged
invasion of ukraine
from multiple directions with air sea
and land capabilities
and this is actually in line with what
our intelligence services predicted over
a long period of time because we saw the
build-up
around ukraine with air sea and land
forces
we see of course that they're moving
towards
kiev we also
see
the
rhetoric
the messages
which is strongly indicating that the
aim is to
change government to change
and remove
the democratically elected government in
kiev we are in close contact with the
government of
ukraine
we are
of course monitoring the situation very
closely
um it is still a fluid situation
uh what we have seen is that um the
ukrainian forces are fighting bravely
and are actually able to
inflict damage
on the invading russian forces
but again it is
a very fluid and uh and
an evolving situation
nato allies expressed at the
summit today
that they
provide support to ukraine they are
ready to continue to provide support to
ukraine
military support financial support
humanitarian support
and then i think we all have to judge
how things evolves
but the message from
nato leaders and also from from
from finland and sweden eu
is that we are there to support ukraine
we have support ukraine for many years
and we continue to provide support
we'll go to the national press agency of
ukraine
uh mr national news agency of ukraine
secretary general in the current uh
situation which we observe now in
ukraine
does nato uh preserve its uh desire to
assist ukraine with defensive equipment
in particular
can we
expect that nato will provide ukraine
with so badly needed
anti-aircraft equipment thank you so
much so nato allies continue to provide
support to ukraine and was actually at
the meeting today at the uh nato summit
with eu and finland sweden uh allies
announced and also uh informed all their
allies about uh the type of weapons the
type of support and some of that also
includes air defense systems
so so nato allies have and continue to
provide support military
but also different types of equipment
to ukraine then we all realized that of
course in this very evolving and uh
and uh and the
difficult situation it's hard to predict
what would be the
what what what are the possibilities in
the future but allies are providing
support and are very committed to
continue to provide support okay we'll
go to nbc just behind the cameras
thank you mr secretary general there's
concern that nato could get pulled into
this conflict if russia were to shut
down electricity or other services
in ukraine that could spill over into
poland or romania can you say explicitly
whether a russian cyber attack of that
nature would trigger an article 5
collective defense
so we are sending a very clear message
to to russia
that we provide support to our
partner
ukraine and allies provide many
different types of support nato help
ukraine also with their cyber defenses
uh
but then for nato allies we provide the
absolute security guarantees
uh under the washington article five an
attack on one uh will be regarded as an
attack on all and we are clear on this
distinction because it is important to
make sure
that um
we don't have
um even bigger crisis in europe
where a russia
challenge or is threatening
uh or attacking any nato allied country
and that's the reason why we so clearly
send a message that we are there to
protect all allies and every inch of
nato territory
when it comes to cyber attacks
and the risk for incidents and accidents
in for instance in in the black sea
we are
pursuing
mechanisms of deconfliction
to prevent that from happening
uh we have nato allies especially united
states have done that for instance in
syria over a long period of time
uh and we of course are very focused i
spoke with sakura the
nato supreme commander
on that issue recently and he is very
focused on the need to deconflict to
make sure that we don't have instant
accidents that can uh spiral and get out
of control and create a very dangerous
city situation
on cyber
well we have stated that
cyber attacks can trigger
article 5 but we have never
gone into the
position where we give a potential
adversary the privilege of defining
exactly when we trigger article five we
are focused on strengthening our cyber
defenses we are very much aware of that
that's a risk
uh and
and therefore we are stepping up both
the protection of our cyber networks but
also providing support ukraine and we
are very focused on the need for the
confliction okay we'll go to um npr
deutsche bank
thank you terry schultz with mkrmdw uh i
want to know more about the deployment
of the nrf forces please um how many
will be sent where
from where um how long will it take to
get there
thinking about military mobility as
always um and also um what has changed
in your calculation about the threat to
nato territory that has led allies to
make the decision to deploy this for the
first time in history for the purposes
of collective defense thank you
robot has changed over the last
days is of course that there's a full
fledged invasion of a partner
a country that borders several nato
allied countries
and this is the most serious security
crisis we have faced in europe for
decades and therefore we have the high
readiness force we have the nato
response force
and that's the reason why we are
deploying it to
again
prevent any miscalculation any
misunderstanding that
we are not ready to protect and defend
all allies
and and of course this is something all
alas have agreed to do uh thirteen last
agreed
uh but of course especially those in
eastern part alliance are extremely
concerned
they are close to this um
the fighting in in in ukraine and they
also border russia and they have seen
the not only the military buildup and uh
and the ongoing war in ukraine but also
seen the very threatening rhetoric
because this goes far beyond ukraine
this is about how russia is actually
challenging contesting core values for
our security
and demanding that nato should withdraw
all
forces and infrastructure
from almost half of our members
and they said that if you don't do that
if you don't meet their demands there
will be what they call military
technical consequences so we have to
take this seriously and that's exactly
why
we are now deploying the nato response
force
uh for the first time um in a collective
defense
also
context
and
and we speak about thousands of troops
we speak about air
and maritime
capabilities
they
are already actually part of the
standing naval groups
we have
many
planes
operating in the eastern part of the
alliance
and then several allies
have
[Music]
partly already assigned troops and
forces to
to the nato response force we have the
lead elements which are led by uh by by
france we have um
we have the united states which has a
sound assigned thousands of troops to
the nato response force and these will
be deployed to different places in
eastern part of the alliance
well they are partly they're coming from
the united states but but these are also
very much european troops
for instance the the lead element the
vjtf the high readiness joint task force
is now led by by by france
there's a strong german component there
and other allah is also
associated press
lawn cook associated press just to
follow up on that secretary general um
the the uh vjtf can only go to one place
and you have eight allies that are
extremely nervous i mean where where
might you
send it have you identified a particular
weakness
on that eastern flank
but i think we have to understand that
we have many uh
elements uh components of the nato
response force we have increased the
redness of the nato response force and
then i don't speak only about the lead
element or the v j t f the very high
radius joint task force
but but but we speak about
[Music]
more elements than
just that one second we have allies
uh the united states but also not
kingdom other allies that have increased
readiness of forces
uh that are assigned to nato in the nato
response force
so of course these are additional forces
that we can deploy as part of the
broader deployment of the nato response
force i'm not saying that we are
deploying the whole force the size of
the nato response force has been tripled
since 2014 to roughly 40 000 troops
uh
uh i'm not saying we're deploying the
whole thing i'm saying that we are
deploying elements elements of the
leader
also the vjtf and elements of the rest
of the nato response force and and then
it is for sakura to make fine decisions
exactly where the different elements are
deployed but we activated the defense
plans yesterday uh and
and
now
uh the elements
of this force will be deployed or yeah
this theme is being deployed
okay we'll go to tv2
and white
lady and white over there
thanks
tv to norway i'll just follow up on ap
and what terry from npr said how
quick can these
troops
and this force be
deployed
but some of these forces are already
operating because we have sea and air
forces which are also all the part of uh
the nato maritime uh forces operating
from the bayern city down to the
mediterranean
some are air forces
the air component of the nato response
force
and then some of the land forces are
also can move within a few days
because they're part of either the lead
element
which has already high redness or the
other elements that has been put on high
redness
so we speak about pace and some are
already
operating
because we have increased our presence
already
okay we'll try to take a couple of
questions online uh we'll go first to
frankfurt algebra
thomas
thanks a lot good afternoon secretary
general in the statement that has just
been released
it is said that
russia's actions are flagrant rejection
of the principles enshrined in the
nato-russia founding act and then it
continues it is russia that has walked
away from its commitments under the act
does
that mean that nato now considers the
nato-russia pounding act as obsolete
or do nato member states still are they
still bound do they still feel bound by
this document thanks a lot
the nato leaders decided today a
statement very clearly state
the fact that russia has walked away
the nato-russia founding act
is based on some core principles
enshrined in the final founding act and
that is
the respect for
uh
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
all uh uh countries including of course
ukraine
and this has been violated not once but
twice
and has actually constantly violated
violated since 2014 with the illegal
annexation of crimea and the continued
presence of russian forces and
russian-backed separatists in eastern
ukraine in donbass and this is further
violated
with the full-fledged invasion of
ukraine that we have seen over the last
couple of days
um so so so what we have what we see
is that russia show no respect for the
nato russia funding act and of course if
you have a founding act between two
partners nato and russia and one part
doesn't respect that agreement that the
agreement doesn't work
it doesn't function it doesn't
help us to improve our relationship with
the with with russia because even if the
founding act has good provisions and
and good intentions
if these uh intentions and the
provisions and
and the founding act is not respected it
doesn't work so that's the reality the
nato for uh nato russia funding act
doesn't work because one side russia has
violated it over many years but now is
here
uh
extremely
blatant
and flagrant flagrant violation of the
founding out with the invasion of
ukraine
we'll take the next question online also
from greg palket from fox
thank you wanna thank you mr secretary
general uh two quick questions one about
war one about peace do you agree with
some reports of intelligence officials
that kiev could fall within the next say
day or two and despite the bravery of
the fighting that you have cited among
ukrainian soldiers
do you see a defeat inevitable if war
goes on and the quick question about
peace there is discussion uh president
zielinski offering to discuss with
russia
an approach to peace that might include
neutrality for
ukraine would you agree to something
like that
thank you
the first on the situation
on the ground
it is a full invasion of ukraine
they are moving towards kiev
and the stated goal is to
change the government of ukraine
um
it is a very
unpredictable situation therefore not re
speculate but i will pay my respect
to the
ukrainian armed forces uh which are
really
proving their bravery and
their courage by
fighting and standing up against
the
much larger invading russian
force
on potential talks between
the government of ukraine uh president
uh silence and uh and russia
my main message is that this is for
president silanski and the government of
ukraine to decide
what we what we need to see now is that
russia stop
the attack against ukraine that they
withdraw their forces and cease
uh all the
attacks on ukraine that's the
the easiest the fastest and the best way
to peace
so if they want uh
uh
peace then it's just stop to attack
ukraine
and if we call on russia to do exactly
that
okay we'll go to ntv
yes
from ntv secretary general two short
questions first you're a statistician
and so far with regard to risk you have
already evaluate
the the risk and the threat against nato
coming from russia particularly you you
foresee the playbook of russia and so my
first question is
what is the risk that this conflict
spread
uh
where and what might be the end goal of
russia and my second question is you
have at the top of your the tip of your
fingers
the security of one billion
citizen in the transatlantic area so you
met with on btc all the leaders can you
reassure the public opinion that
if there is a genuine threat coming from
because the rhetoric the aggressive
rhetoric of russia its behavior is
acceptable that all member states are
committed to defend and protect every
single centimeter of
nato thank you
in the meeting today with nato leaders
it was a very strong
message of unity a very strong message
of resolve that we need to stand
together
not only in words but also in deeds
so we agreed a strong statement
calling russia to stop
the attacks on ukraine to withdraw its
forces
but also
we agreed to continue to provide support
to ukraine and also continue to
strengthen our presence in eastern part
alliance
to prevent
any attack on any nato allied country
we have a defensive presence in the east
we
are
[Music]
increasing our presence not to provoke a
conflict but to prevent the conflict and
as long as there is no doubt about
nato's readiness to protect and defend
all allies
and our commitment to the core message
the core task of nato one for all for
one an attack on one ally will be
regardless attack on all
then no ally will be attacked and that
will prevent the conflict
uh
and that will preserve peace for nato
allies and for one billion people
and that's the reason why we communicate
so clearly and that's the reason why we
are deploying more troops in the eastern
part alliance
to make sure that there is no
possibility to misunderstand
awareness to protect and defend all
allies and again this is to preserve
peace
to prevent an attack
and to prevent
that the war which is going on in
ukraine
um
spill over to any nato other country
and uh and that's that that was the
message from nato leaders today
and that was also the message when i met
with many of them in the g7
uh yesterday
and that is also of course a message
when we speak to close partners finland
sweden and the european union
because we all are concerned and
russia's attack on ukraine is
more than an attack on ukraine i said
it's a devastating horrendous attack on
innocent
uh
people in ukraine but it's also an
attack on the whole european security
order and that's the reason why we take
it so extremely seriously
uh
secretary general one question on on
ukraine's request
for turkey to to close the bosphorus to
for russian warships is that be was that
discussed today and one follow-up on the
question just ask
we heard today from the lithuanian
foreign minister saying that when we
lose ukraine today we will be fighting
for nato later
would you say that the statement is
exaggerated
thank you
so on on the bosphorus that was not an
issue um uh on on
on
the potential attack or any potential
attack on the nato other country
that has been our message throughout the
whole day that was the message from the
nato leaders in the summit today
is that is that
is that we are there to protect enough
in all ours nato is the strongest
military alliance in the world
and make no mistake we are there to
protect and defend all allies and every
inch of nato territory and we convey
that message again and again
both in words but also in deeds
and uh and that's the way to prevent war
that's when to prevent an attack to
pursue peace and we have done so for
more than 70 years and will continue to
do it also in the light of
the attack on
ukraine
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference
thank you so much
for the reuters live service
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
this is